après l'espace les nouvelles
technologies internet c'est le nom des
nouvelles autoroutes de l'information
qui parcourt le monde avec un simple
clavier d'ordinateur vous pouvez donc
avoir accès pratiquement à toutes les
banques de données et tout savoir sur
tout ou presque
l'amérique nous précèdent bien entendu
dans ce domaine est actuellement on en
est à un nouveau un nouvel abonné toutes
les 20 secondes dans le monde patricia
charnley
et si on leur aux explications bienvenue
dans le monde d'internet
en pénétrant dans cette banque mondiale
de données vous rejoignez les 30
millions de brancher au sens propre qui
naviguent jour et nuit sur ce réseau
informatique planétaire internet a été
créé dans les années 60 par les
militaires américains
puis les universitaires se sont
connectés à un réseau informatique
reliant des ordinateurs dans le monde
entier s'est alors développée pour y
avoir accès il suffit de disposer d'un
micro ordinateur et de souscrire un
abonnement environ 250 francs par mois
vous pouvez alors communiqué avec la
planète exemple avec bill clinton le
président américain reçoit tous vos
messages et la maison blanche y répond
au-delà de cette messagerie universel on
trouve tout sur internet
quasiment tout ce que les hommes ont
écrit ou photographiés au cours des 50
dernières années y compris un bon nombre
de reproduction de choses plus anciennes
y compris l'information touristique des
informations de jeu
la manière de commander une pizza la
filmographie de bertrand testèrent le
plan du shopping à singapour
résumant tout internet est aussi
gigantesque banque d'informations ainsi
cette petite entreprise de bobigny en
région parisienne spécialisée en
mécanique électronique a découvert dans
les ordinateurs des plus grandes
universités américaines des programmes
informatiques très utile pour son
développement
les chercheurs américains expliquant sur
le réseau leurs plus récents travaux
il faut qu'on fasse attention de ne pas
réinventer des choses qui existent parce
que c'est une perte de temps et d'argent
donc pour nous c'est vraiment un moyen
de production
cette information et ça se compte
vraiment en argent à ce niveau là
l'accès à toutes ces informations est
gratuit c'est l'un des principes de base
d'internet
de même l'absence de chef la plus grande
liberté règne sur le réseau certains
parlent déjà de la naissance de la
démocratie électronique internet s'est
développé de façon tellement forte que
maintenant on peut plus l'arrêter et on
peut considérer que toute population qui
est soumise à la connaissance va plutôt
aller vers la démocratie qu vers le
totalitarisme
al'inverse internet a déjà ses
détracteurs
les un reproche au réseau d'être déjà
saturé les autres disent qu'il est
polluée par les trafiquants en tout
genre
quel que soit son évolution internet
aura révolutionné l'accès au savoir
et vive le progrès vous pourrez
téléphonez à votre fiancée ou à votre
maman n'importe où n'importe quand et
discrètement et cela grâce un minuscule
appareil de poche
le be bop c'est son nom n'est pas plus
gros qu'une calculette et grâce à des
bornes installées un peu partout en
ville
il permet d'appeler de la rue mais aussi
de chez soi
l'expérience a été lancée aujourd'hui à
strasbourg reportage de la iii sur place
philippe bête et andré muller la scène
vous paraîtra cocasse mais il faudra
vous y habituer dès la rentrée 2000
téléphones de bosch circuleront un titre
expérimental au coeur de strasbourg
ce sera la première application en
france du téléphone numérique sans fil
en procède dès maintenant à
l'installation des émetteurs relais qui
capteront les appels et les acheminerons
sur le réseau téléphone
il suffira de localiser un émetteur de
sont rapprochés à quelques centaines de
mètres pour appeler même depuis la rue
270 rôle et seront opérationnels d'ici
la fin de l'année dans des quartiers
très fréquentés
dans un souci d'esthétique les banques
émettrices ont été installées à
l'intérieur chez des commerçants
volontaires
france télécom a dû renoncer à ses
projets d'implantation sur la voie
publique
strasbourg a un patrimoine historique
qui ne faut pas défigurer les relais
pointe elles seront facilement
identifiables grâce à une signalisation
spécifique mais l'on pourra aussi
utiliser son téléphone de poche chez soi
en louant une bande domestique france
télécom veut faire de pointe elle un
appareil pratique accessible et très
répandue la minute de téléphones sans
fil reviendra trois fois moins cher
qu'une communication de voiture ce ne
sera pas vraiment donné mais ça fera
tellement chic
paris près de trente mille personnes se
sont bousculées au premier salon
international du pin's les amateurs ont
fantasmé sur le pin's le plus cher au
monde une carte du koweït en or ornée
d'un diamant qui vaut plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de francs sur des images de
gilles ragon reportage de françoise
david alias mary poppins des pin's il en
a plein son sac
pensez donc il en possède au total près
de 2000 c'est vous dire s'il n'a pas
hésité à venir de sa voie pour cette
super braderie histoire de pratiquer des
échanges entre amateurs éclairés
j'ai 60 ans et je suis encore aider je
suis collectionneur du beaucoup de chose
je le fais la collection de parfums de
chopes de bière j'ai presque amusé chez
moi j'ai 758 lumière et je suis
impatient je crois que c'est aux
actionnaires de pid parce que la couleur
et la beauté de la chose et peut on peut
le mettre en sens inverse d'ailleurs il
n'ya pas si longtemps le bim s'appelait
tout simplement un insigne de
boutonnière on expose on cherche au
parlement
je peux passat est rien 1
le collectionneur fou est maintenant
bien équipé classeurs ou présentoirs est
spécial et quand on en a pas incroyable
des pin's à l'ancienne autrement dit des
badges et on l'urss la différence avec
le pin's français c'est que ce n'est pas
un publicitaire en général ses taux mais
moratti
c'est la journée de la femme agent du
travail chiasso commères une porte à un
pin's cela ne se voit plus cela se sent
ce ping se diffuse pendant 24 heures les
effluves de votre parfum favori
véloce complet
il est deux ans - 10 nov la france est
frappée par là
la marraine et suissesses ont délaissé
le medad à défaut d'école ce sont les
pubs la règle du jeu est d'une
simplicité biblique
explication d'un expert jules le but de
retourner de faire une pipe d'attendre
et d'essayer de les retourner votre
tournée et lancé des slogans retourner
le plus possible hu pour en prendre un
maximum et comment se les procurent bas
on sait les achètent
l'ennui c'est que c'est un petit peu
cher on ne me fera un paquet des six
hamel comment tu as découvert les
peuples qu'ils les 11 cantons et nouveau
les les ondes les alentours ikon effet
demandé je croyais fêter une histoire de
nous les durant sa pièce amène n'était
pas si loin de la vérité
le lancement des pommes sur le marché
français s'apparente ont été assurés
d'un nouveau cottage distribution
gratuite à la sortie des écoles
publicité et produits associés
rien n'a été laissé au hasard en dix
jours la société française qui a racheté
les droits aux américains avant de plus
de 10 millions de jeux prendre on a
pensé que pour vraiment
entretenir le phénomène il fallait qu'il
y ait un concept derrière c'est à dire
que on se lève le matin pub où on mange
prague à midi on se couche avec paul les
quoi vous sera sans doute qu'ils passent
une périssables car dans les courbes et
comme ailleurs
mon match aso
depuis qu'internet
révolutionne les relations entre les
hommes en faisant tomber les barrières
des frontières nos vies nos sentiments
notre quotidien risque de devenir de
moins en moins concret est de plus en
plus virtuel exemple les tamagotchi une
invention japonaise que l'on peut
traduire pas adorable petit oeuf des
poussins virtuel qu'on soigne qu'on
élève qu'on nourrit un joueur qui fait
fureur au japon et qui débarque en
france
notre enquête de ce soir mené par
stéphane haumant marié d'une bonne eau
et christian hottin est intitulé
virtuellement votre innocent lui même à
salut à tous je m'appelle net et qiu bo
et je suis chanteuse
voix de lolita et mensurations idéales
la première artiste virtuel doit tout à
l'ordinateur datexco a vendu peu de
disques mais son clip a fait le tour du
monde tout simplement cyber star elle a
aussi ses avantages
la chanteuse ne mange pas pas de
scandale et surtout elle n'est jamais
malade
les univers virtuels passionne les
japonais dès le plus jeune âge quand il
se vend 100 mille consoles de jeux en
france
il s'en vend 1 million au japon 10 fois
plus akihabara un quartier de tokyo
surnommée la ville de l'électronique
dans un pays comme le japon éclaté en
3300 il internet s'est imposé en
quelques mois comme un formidable outil
de communication mais dans les
cybercafés la recherche d'emploi sur le
net ou le shopping virtuel sont dépassés
un très sérieux moines bouddhistes
propose un cimetière virtuel c'est la
dernière nouveauté vous choisissez la
forme de votre tombe et vous y
inscrivait le nom de l'être cher
vous pouvez ainsi vous recueillir devant
votre ordinateur
plus convivial mais tout aussi virtuel
le tamagotchi un petit oeuf
électroniques dont il faut s'occuper
comme d'un animal domestique en
pianotant sur ce béton cellulaire
il a un petit peu faim et qu'on adore
être parce qu'il est bien de jouer
iconographe l'éducation a très important
c'est qu'il est content il est jeune il
faut lever à 9h et le coucher à 8 heures
si on les ducaux mal avec un ne respecte
plus les horaires il ne mange plus
devient sale et il maigrir aujourd'hui
dans les rues de tokyo le poussin
virtuel se négocie au marché noir
les magasins sont en rupture de stock
alors les vendeurs à la sauvette en
profite
les prix flambent 2500 francs pièce 25
fois le prix officiel 7 millions
d'exemplaires vendus en quelques mois un
succès foudroyant
un japonais sur six se déclarent prêts à
adopter un tamagotchi le tamagotchi
c'est mieux qu'un chien on donne de
l'affection mais il est moins exigeant
le fabricant se tournent désormais vers
l'exportation 20 millions de poussins
virtuels devraient être vendus cette
année aux états unis et en europe
et le voilà en france on en a déjà vendu
25 milles en 3 semaines dans ce magasin
maintenant il faut s'inscrire sur liste
d'attenté
vous avez la possibilité de réserver si
vous le désirez mais qu'est ce qui
pousse les enfants et par la même
occasion les parents à acheter ce petit
oeuf à 99 francs c'est mieux d'avoir un
animal au moins ça leur affront a été un
petit peu responsable aussi c'est comme
un petit enfant on va aller lever lui
donner à manger une changé bref un
personnage électronique avec des envies
et des besoins plus qu'un simple objet
les professionnels ne s'y sont pas
trompés c'est un produit qui est
affectif c'est un produit qui est
personnel c'est un produit avec lequel
on peut on peut presque dialoguer donc
ça c'est tous les ingrédients du succès
pour un joueur comme lui dans la mer il
fait fureur dans les cours de récré les
enfants font des concours de longévité
si on le néglige il peut mourir une tête
de mort à côté des figures parfois deux
le faut lui donner à manger pas trop ce
qu après penser beaucoup le tamagotchi
et comme tous les phénomènes de mode
il ne durera qu'un temps mais le
transfert des motions vers une machine
suscite déjà bien des questions elle
paraît dangereux ci devient crew comme
tout et machines
pas du tout si la de sylla une
affectivité qui est normal autour de lui
je crois qu'on peut s'en amuser mais en
revanche ça ne doit pas remplacer
quelque chose il reste encore des
enfants qui préfèrent le réel mais déjà
à fabricant prépare un nouveau produit
un bébé virtuel qu'il faudra élever
jusqu à l'âge adulte en trois dimensions
et en couleurs on n'arrête pas le
progrès